nous sommes dans les studios du
troisième étage de la can factory la
scène on est vraiment dans les antres de
l'andra alors vous avez reconnu gilles
verdez qui s'est déguisée toujours très
sobre gilles verdez c'est toujours très
sobre hawaïen derrière moi il ya un fond
vert se font vers vous le connaissez
peut-être pas c'est grâce à ce fonds
vert qu'on peut mettre des images
derrière par exemple imaginer verdet
s'est mis un peu on en dix ans mère au
pla maire
ah c'est ça c'est très bien alors
évidemment quand on est sur un fond vert
ont choisi des couleurs qui ne vont pas
nuire au fond vert donc évidemment fait
part en rouge envers mr bah oui mais oui
donc voilà alors on peut changer un peu
la montagne voilà la laguna mais j'étais
obligé de lui mais parce que c'est
ridicule jean non mais c'est pourquoi
vous en mettez toujours trop et vous
n'avez pas un calme calme alors et puis
surtout le fond vert c'est l'outil
principal de ce qui fonde la météo et ce
à la météo c'est très compliqué à faire
alors des hommes météo la sécheresse et
là je ne sais même pas comment par
lasser brest ou et brest brest là c'est
pas la cepi paraît pas réparé par et
paris lille les lois là et c'était
compliqué alors gilles puisque vous êtes
devant alors lâchez votre bon vieux
ridicule là et essayer de me faire une
météo on va en être capable là il fera
22 degrés à bordeaux c'est une
température estivale alors qu'à la
rochelle 25 degrés c'est le top du top
et la 23° 23 degrés à strasbourg
attention vous aurez froid strasbourg
mais à lille va degrés c'est le pire du
pire aller mais c'est une belle ville je
vais vous donner trois mots qu'il faudra
placer dans votre météo d'accord de
allez je vais t'appeler m 2
vous allez me placer bruine bruine et
crachats les crachins c'est mieux parce
que pareil non c'est pas pareil d'accord
parce qu'il peut brûler et crash in est
bon alors vous savez qu'il ya un fond
vert mais là il ya un écran vous êtes
devant ben à les y attendait bernard
montiel première
voilà chers amis bonsoir je te reste
heureux de vous accueillir pour cette
météo évidemment voulez savoir quel
temps il fera demain
eh bien on va en parler maintenant alors
regardez déjà là ça commence
un des trucs et la moto c'est la mer ça
de la bruine évidemment c'est pressenti
ça commence
c'est le matin ça va bien se passer là
au plus tôt là c'est carrément du
crachin du crachin sur le pays
lillois les hauts de france et bien
regardez là où la mer c'est pas fini il
ya c'est le polype assez merveilleux
pays bas où il fait toujours beau
un petit coup d'oeil sur les
températures demain donc une france
vraiment divisé en 2 1 comme l'a dit
géraldine tout allait en rousse et
ensoleillé vous allez pouvoir sortir vos
plus beaux tee shirt ou vos plus beaux
veste en daim comme benjamin castaldi
par la tension dans le sud de la france
ça va se refroidir avec des températures
aux alentours de 10 degrés on opte pour
une petite laine un petit blouson en
cuir un petit manteau mi saison
est ce que c'est vrai qu'il faut se
méfier de ces températures ces bâtards
y'a plus de saison ma bonne dame attend
à droite deux ados 2 et quoi
voilà bah là ça va beaucoup mieux voyez
voilà la sénace et voilà c'est logique
quant à prix d'or je vous racontais
bernard montiel bon tricheurs vous êtes
un tricheur j'avais gagné hockey qui ne
sais quoi comme je suis un gentleman
je vous laisse gagner c'est vrai ballon
et le faire je le fais ça me fait
plaisir
voilà il n'y a pas de raison ça va faire
la différence de certains jeunes recchi
pas les règles en permanence 2 3 go
commun d'être un tour à tour ses
lectrices pas au moins de quoi tout
n'est pas possible
gérer c'est pas possible
je suis contente oui je sais mais bon on
fait la course à l'arrière et ma musique
je n'ai jamais je vous ai compagne ne
sait pas faire votre chef là mécha
supportable dont ils vont rentrer dans
ses camions luxe et que vous connaissez
par coeur il ya 40 ballons le premier
qui a pété tous les ballons remporté la
grande finale
uniquement à mon top série ne trichez
pas comme d'habitude je suis pas ta
alors si je ne compterais balle alors
maîtriser tout le temps alors je vous
dire je me prenez le comme vous voulez
vous affichera les y aller at nous
attendait mon top série de wayne sera
attention 3 2 qui va égorger un poulet
série la 3 2
[Musique]
il
jamais les croyants tout le monde aime
ça incroyable mais j'ai perdu et s'est
éclatée comme ça comment on va vous avez
perdu s'est désolé c'était patron évoque
sa victoire celui ci sera donc de
finacle a dit d'accord alors vous avez
c'est l'odeur c'est lui de nouveau
patron exactement un très très très bien
je réagis ah ouais ça veut dire que vous
avez vu arriver avant dans l'émission
oui oui plutôt
c'est pas sûr c'est moi je vous dis ça
je dis rien c'est bon et à des missions
à faire avec les deux suisses